[Music]
where are you
where
can you are you able to step out with me
okay let's just step towards the back of
the car okay
[Applause]
what's going on man
[Music]
you need the whole ride on yeah where
you coming from
where where are you coming from
leave the ride home man they'll
leave right
okay i don't understand what you're
saying
you're trying to get a ride home
no
say it again for me leave your ride home
the ride home the ride home yeah okay
where are you coming from the ride home
is that the name of it
the ride home like where is this
this
winter guard ride on
okay where are you headed to
my house okay where's your house right
here
okay guys have your id on you
i'm sure
if you don't have it on you it's okay
you can just uh we'll get your name
dated work
it's okay man just give us your name
number seven
right now
that's your date of birth yep okay and
what's your name
chase man chase what
nina m-i-n-a
don't lose your stuff here buddy
[Music]
chase just stay on the truck floor right
now okay all right
[Music]
hey chase if you want to leave that in
the seat then can we step over in this
uh this parking lot over here so we can
get you out of the road out of the
roadway yeah okay did you actually leave
the keys man
um and i'll explain everything
[Music]
[Applause]
walk okay i just want to get you out of
the road man
do you guys want to go around
okay it's chase right
yes sir okay chase so the reason why we
pulled you out of the car well first of
all we found you asleep at the light you
know how long you've been there
nope okay a minute okay have you been
drinking tonight at all
a little bit okay um so right now the
concern is uh for your ability to drive
so i'm just gonna ask you would you be
willing to answer some questions would
you be willing to do some sobriety
exercises for us tonight absolutely not
okay is your id in the car
yep okay no problem just uh if you're
only on this officer's car i'll come
right back to you man okay chase
all right
so generally what we do is we run you
through some medical questions when you
do the extra the field sorry exercises
if you don't want to do those you don't
have to um but right now you're asking
us to make base our decision on your
ability to drive on what we've seen so
far and what we've seen so far is you
asleep in the vehicle you reek of
alcohol
it's obviously been drinking you told us
that you came from the bar
so i just want to present you the
opportunity again would you like to do
field spreading exercises
no okay
all right go ahead and turn around for
your back
okay what i'll do with that pocket knife
is i'll just take it and i'll leave it
in your truck that's okay
um you won't be able to take it to you
take it with you
is there anything out of the car that
you need your wallet anything like that
oh man okay uh and you have your phone
on you yeah this gentleman's gonna
search you he'll just pull out
everything and everything that he finds
is gonna go with you okay and nothing
you need out of the truck
okay all right
let's take a walk which side
[Music]
you got nothing on you that's gonna poke
me stop me anything like that
just like i know the knife but it's
closed pocket knife right nope that's it
all right
so
chase have you had a diy in the past
uh
easier to go butt first
uh document how much cash is in your
wallet and what's on your property so
cell phone correct
all right
got your wallet with miscellaneous
cards
all right i'm going to count this out
real quick
that's 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
is that good for you yeah
you